déjà qu'on est à moi si vous rentrez du
liban vous avez fait un assez long
séjour vous allez rapport que ces images
où sommes nous eh bien là nous abordons
les anti claude phénicienne et nous
sommes à saïda l'antique si don qui est
située au sud du liban au sud de
beyrouth
et nous voyons ici le château de la mer
qu'on appelle encore le cas là tel bar
et qui est un château qui remonte à
l'époque croisée le pont que vous voyez
qui relie ce château à la côte a
d'ailleurs été emporté plusieurs fois
par la mère qui est assez souvent
mauvaise dans ce coin et on l'a
reconstruit régulièrement on l'a
reconstruit les deux fois et j'ai été
emporté
nous voyons ici ce château vue de la est
là et bien là nous allons vers beyrouth
la bo fossé beyrouth que nous apercevons
tout à fait dans le bas et ne descendons
la montagne ainsi la très belle route
à
on sert son linge facilement un bon
souvenir vivant
oui nous sommes ici en plein bureau
comme vous le voyez puisque nous
arrivons enfin sur la cornée parce
qu'ici nous sommes sur la corniche et
nous sommes au bord de la mer c'est un
quartier qui est en train de se
construire
[Musique]
évidemment il ya très spéciaux elles
sont très belles c'est là à vous les
verrous thèmes vont passer en général
les mois d'été se reposer des chaleurs
[Musique]
oui à mon avis ce sont les plus mauvais
conducteurs du monde c'est certainement
le pays le plus dangereux pour conduire
une automobile
nous arrivons maintenant comme vous le
voyez sur la corniche la grande corniche
de beyrouth qui est un des endroits les
plus agréables de la ville double
circulation
oui il ya d'ailleurs un autoroute qui
monte vers le nord de beyrouth
les immeubles hôtels et spectra moderne
à lesparre ces immeubles viennent de se
construire un certain nombre sont en
construction et d'autres ont été finis
il ya simplement quelques mois
c'est un des pays du moyen-orient les
plus modernes près ce nom c'est
certainement le pays du moyen-orient qui
est le plus à la pointe du progrès à
l'heure actuelle voici ci à cinéma
d'ailleurs ultramoderne qui vient de
terminer voici ici le quartier des
grands hôtels qui sont mélangés
d'ailleurs avec des bouges avec le liban
est le pays des contrastes aussi une des
voix les plus modernes de la ville nous
arrivons au quartier musulman
[Musique]
c'est là d'ailleurs où il ya les
fameuses émeutes en 58 c'était un des
quartiers on sait le plus battu la
circulation est très intense et très
difficile à la ville des rues sont
étroites
ils ont l'habitude de se reposer comme
ça sur le sol on a réussi sont en plein
travail cela ils vendent des bananes ah
oui c'est sûr les commerçants
voilà le retour de l'école il aime
beaucoup ses métiers ambulants et
beaucoup de petits métiers comme ça
beaucoup
voilà justement le vendeur de flers les
vendeurs de fruits très coloré c'est
très coloré et c'est les pommes sont
extrêmement belge et du palais galette
c'est du pain on l'appelle le père arabe
d'ailleurs un plan simple à une fameuse
piste je suis le vendeur de pistaches
salées non salées d'ailleurs ils sont
très friands de tout ce genre de
friandises et avec cet appareil
grieg les pistaches c'est une cheminée
jeu véritable cheminer avec un petit
drapeau libanais en eau et voilà le
fiacre beaucoup non c'est peut-être le
fiacre de beyrouth le voir nous voici là
près du port près du grand hôtel de
beyrouth
on se baigne dans ses parages on m'a
demandé beaucoup mais ce sont surtout
les étrangers qui séjournent à beyrouth
qui se baignent le libanais n'est pas
très porté sur l'eau et surtout sur
l'eau de mer
[Musique]
cet endroit est l'un des plus beaux de
beyrouth
[Musique]
et porte le nom de grottes aux pigeons
une couleur ils doivent pas passer
extraordinaire
le vert en particulier que l'on peut
voir mélangé au bleu sombre consulter
couleurs splendides
[Musique]
aussi un des grands restaurants chics de
beyrouth d'où l'on peut voir la fameuse
grotte aux pigeons que voici
probablement ainsi dénommée parce que
pas mal d'oiseaux viennent y faire leur
nid cet endroit est absolument faux airs
et lorsqu'on le voit en plein soleil
avec ses rochers blancs qui se détache
sur une mer bleue elle est verte
lorsqu'il y à une profondeur moins
grandes mais là il y a déjà une certaine
profondeur peut se promener en bateau on
passe à travers cette porte et l'on
ressort de l'autre côté
[Musique]
e
et maintenant de titan beyrouth nous
filons vers la montagne la splendide
montagne du malaise et nous nous
enfonçons dans le mont liban beaucoup de
bruit malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
brebis qui ont dévasté pratiquement le
pays et qui ont arraché toutes les
herbes
il est question d'ailleurs d'interdire
la brebis dans le pays et nous arrivons
à byblos c'est tout byblos ceci est le
point d'eau autour de laquelle s'est
construite byblos nous avons une vue
d'ensemble maintenant ce n'est pas très
loin des johnny labbe et johnny est tout
à côté et nous voyons l'ancien port
phénicien 2,8 bros ou les foules sont
extrêmement active et nous avons juste
cette maison qui doit être détruite dans
quelque temps pour pouvoir continuer les
foules
[Musique]
le minaret qui donne sur la ville de
byblos la ville moderne byblos qui est
situé tout à côté de ces fouilles avant
l'exemple d'un très beau sarcophage
phéniciens il ya plus de 4000 ans et il
a plus de 4000 ans on n'a jamais
retrouvé le couvercle extrêmement lourd
ces sarcophages était d'ailleurs enfoui
au fond depuis deux ans voilà où étaient
les sarcophages on est allé chercher au
fond mais ce qui a été difficile c'était
de les mettre à l'époque
d'où byblos est dominé par ce château
qui remonte aux croisés et qui a été
construit avec les matériaux que les
croisés ont trouvé sur place sont pas
des poutres sont des colonnes de granit
qui remonte à l'époque romaine
ils ont été utilisés pour consolider les
murs
[Musique]
ils les ont abattus les ont scié en
général les six ans 3 qui représente l
épaisseur des murs et ils les ont
incluses dans les murs ceci est un
trophée par une une bombe un obus turcs
les colonnes sont ou ont été laissés là
voilà les magasins lot de graines
surtout le plus vieux murs du monde tu
remontes à l'époque néolithique le
temple des obélisques qui a été
transportée et qui est un des choses les
plus curieuses de byblos ce sont des
monuments si l'on peut dire des
obélisques votifs chaque obélisque
représentant un membre de la famille le
père la mère les enfants par exemple au
fond c'est l'hôtel des sacrifices voilà
encore
[Musique]
voici l'hôtel des sacrifices où l'on
faisait des sacrifices non humains et le
puy du sang ou leur quille et le sang
qui s'écoulait de l'hôtel nous passons
maintenant à l'époque néolithique
voici une tombe
c'était une jarre en terre cuite dans le
plus l on enterrait le mort avec ses
bijoux en position foetale les
instruments de cuisine de ces dames
aussi un mortier ou il pilet le blé pour
faire leur farine en particulier en
marquera gueule pilon occupe presque
tout le mortier et voici la batterie de
cuisine complète
[Musique]
l'été un théâtre romain cette fois ci
nous faisons un bond de plusieurs
milliers d'années dans l'espace a dit
blanc toujours à byblos il était
déplacée on l'a mis en bordure de mer
l'a complètement dès qu'on l'a
complètement déplacé pierre par pierre
pour fouiller en dessous ce théâtre
absolument délicieux et il pouvait
contenir 40 mille spectateurs quand il
était complet on n'a plus qu'un tout
petit morceau reconstituer intégralement
legault delaporte phénicienne
extrêmement émouvant voir second tour
n'a qu elle apporte tourner un autre
type de mortier et le pressoir à huile
l'huile s'écouler dans la rigole été
recueillis dans le bol c'est un exemple
d'habitation néolithique monocellulaires
la colonnade romaine l'escalier d'entrée
de la ville phénicienne et toujours les
habitations mono séminaire les chambres
mme de cellulaires
ils ont fait un bond dans le liban et
nous trouvons maintenant nous sommes à
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres de
byblos nous sommes là à jezzine c'est
déjà là un type insa
nous sommes à peu près 1000 mètres
d'altitude gésine célèbre par ses pommes
ses cascades et son tremblement de terre
il ya deux ans extrêmement graves ont
lieu plusieurs centaines de morts
c'est une région extrêmement bien eric
gay culture un terrain où on fait des
cultures en terrasses qui sont typiques
du liban les libanais ont réussi à
certains endroits à cultiver la montagne
jusqu'au sommes nés et on cultive la
beaucoup de pommiers les pommiers se
sont très bien acclimaté et les pommes
libanaises sont tout à fait remarquables
la basilique maronite de jezzine ya une
différence entre les montagnes les
endroits parfaitement appeler d'autres
c'est extrêmement variable c'est le
genre d'habitation classique avant
habitations riche libanaise voilà un
type beaucoup plus pauvres les deux
habitations sont situées l'une en face
de l'autre d'ailleurs sur la même route
une petite fille du manège avec ses
nattes les charmantes
et on rentre la belge mais si jacques
robert boursiers pour ce premier voyage
[Musique]